McElligott: The title of your talk is
"Time Poverty Amidst Digital Abundance."
Is time poverty mostly a perceptual thing?
I don't know how much that is actually a term of art
or just a coinage of yours?
Is it more, would you say, a trick
we are playing on ourselves?
Or is it also different populations
that are having different challenges?
Because certainly the person who is working three jobs
has a different kind of time poverty
than the person who just has that calendar.
Wajcman: Well, here particularly what's very strong
is the kind of culture of busyness.
I was lucky enough to do a radio interview
with William Gibson once on BBC radio
when his most recent book had come out.
It was a couple of years ago
--you know, the science fiction writer.
And he said to me: saying you're incredibly busy now
is just saying you're incredibly rich.
That's the kind of equivalent now.
And I've had people say to me at some of my talks...
a colleague of mine in Cambridge actually,
who I've known for years said to me...
if I go back to my office now and there are no emails
I'll feel like a loser. I feel like a failure.
But this is so much a measure of kind of our sense of
self and who we are and our importance and our status.
That it's very hard to deconstruct.
It's that culture, actually.
I have to say that when I first came to America,
like 30 years ago,
my first job was in Edinburgh,
various people said to me, you know
when you get to America all those American academics
they're all gonna tell you that they're
incredibly busy.
You've got to be prepared for this.
It is just part of what's culturally valued, I think.
And that I think makes leisure
such an undervalued activity.